hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar simplify the development and
implementation of diagnostic testing in
European Laboratories my name is illness
latini and I'm a marketing specialist in
genetic testing solution division for
thermal fissure scientific in a mere
region today's education webinar is
presented by labroads and brought to you
by therm official scientific
we encourage you to participate by
submitting any questions you may have
for our speakers during the presentation
to do so simply type your question into
the ask a question box and click Send
we will have a live q a session at the
end of the presentation where we will
try to answer as many of the questions
as time allows
you may also submit any technical issues
in the chat box if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation now I
would like to hand over the time
tomorrow's Pinal from Health Catalyst
group who will provide an introduction
of the speaker and the presentation Mara
over to you
thank you so much it is great to be here
today as you just said we are here to
answer your questions but we're going to
talk about simplifying the development
of diagnostic testing in a clinical lab
before I begin I want to put out a
disclaimer here for thermal Fisher
Scientific we appreciate their
sponsorship of this event but as you can
see they're not endorsing recommending
or promoting any user application of
thermal Fisher Scientific products so
I'll give you a moment to read that
and before we start our event what I'd
like to do is ask for a poll and all of
you should see this on your screen we'd
like to understand the relative level of
experience
in this group so my question is in the
last five years how many molecular tests
have your lab developed and if you even
if you are not the person who is
developing the specific test but you're
in a lab that has developed tasks can
you please fill this out if you're not a
lab developer that you can skip the
question three options you've developed
no tests one or two tests or three or
more tests
and I'll give everybody
um just about
30 seconds to answer this question
and then we will all view the result but
it will give us a sense of how many how
much experience in the group so we can
customize our presentation today as much
as possible
just 10 more seconds
thank you very much
and when we see our group here what you
could see is we have a number of people
um just over a third who have not done
any molecular test development some with
one or two and then um just under a
third with three or more so thank you
for that and we look forward to our
presentation
so when we talk to our presentation we
have four learning objectives today one
is we'll go through the basics of
describing the different types of in
vitro diagnostic tests most importantly
we'll talk about the difference between
an ihd an in-house and an ivd in vitro
tests we will list the benefits and some
of the challenges of running either an
ivd or an IHG and we will explain at a
high level how these tests are created
and regulated so this will be a good
basic
understanding especially for those who
have not developed a test or just
developed a few tests for those
developing more we will actually go into
some details that we believe will be
important
our core as we've talked about are seven
questions we will go through that
diagnostic test terminology to ensure we
all have the same Baseline and then we
will ask these questions briefly what is
an ihd what is an ivd why use one versus
another who typically uses one versus
another when and how to develop those
tasks how do they compare and lastly and
critically importantly how can a lab
protect the important work they do and
their intellectual property
so as we do that I'm very pleased to
introduce our speakers I didn't give my
background but I'll very briefly say
that I'm managing director of Health
Catalyst group professor of practice at
Arizona University my whole career has
based has been based in the business of
clinical and research Diagnostics I had
the privilege of serving as president of
genzyme genetics and CEO of roast tissue
Diagnostics
but today we have two speakers who are
true experts in the Diagnostics
um Community worldwide
um Dr Marilyn Owens and uh my Michael
Donovan uh Dr Michael Donovan um Marilyn
is a senior health care executive with
more than 40 Years of extensive
management experience establishing and
leading Clinical Reference Labs
including academic medical centers
private and Hospital labs around the
world she has broad scientific
background in Immunology infectious
disease oncology genetics and molecular
biology she has substantial lab
operating experience with p l x p l
responsibility in large and small labs
her experience as I said spans the world
so she has run labs in the U.S in Europe
and in Asia she has done startups M A
and strategic planning she's an
experienced teacher Mentor coach and
graduate training in business as well as
the science
Michael is equally impressive he's a
registered patent attorney specializing
in patent prosecution and intellectual
property licensing and commercialization
with a specific focus on science related
Technologies he has an academic
background in microbiology and a PhD in
Immunology after leaving Private
Practice he worked as intellectual
property council at the translational
genomics Institute also called tijan and
recently served as system director for
intellectual property at common Spirit
Health today he's a lecturer and head of
program at asu's biomedical Diagnostics
program where he teaches in a variety of
areas including regulatory law Health
economics and bioeconomics so now over
to you
thank you Mara this is Marilyn Owens and
I I'm going to start off with some real
basic uh definitions we all know that
laboratory tests are considered in vitro
which would be uh in the laboratory in a
test tube but the in Vivo tests are are
also extremely important because these
are driven by physicians Physicians do
EKGs blood pressure they will do the
Imaging studies and all of this is
extremely important for Diagnostics
for the in vitro side we have choices of
ivds or ihds and you can see that they
are pretty much the same type of test
they are used to detect or quantify
levels of desired biomarkers of a
various number of types but the
difference between them is that the ivds
are driven by products these are
prepared by vendors and manufactured to
certain standards whereas the ihds
in-house develop tests are driven by the
process at that particular Laboratory
now the differences between those two
are that the
ivdr is regulated by uh by CE ivds and
these require
uh a certain amount of Hoops to jump
through in order to sell products to
clinical labs for the use in consumer
and patient care
they have standardized equipment
qualifications and procedures and
training these are regulated by the
laboratory industry as well as the
government
and these tests must be pre-validated
with the specific type of data analysis
and bioinformatics report in order to be
qualified and clinically validated
before they're approved
with the ihds these are developed by
individual Laboratories and because of
that there can only be performed in the
laboratory that designed it and
validated it they can be transferred
licensed or sold
with few exceptions
the instrument qualification and
training requirements are established by
those individual Laboratories so the
laboratory sets up its own test and says
when it's working and when it's not but
it should follow ISO 15189
at least starting in 2024 that will be a
requirement right now it's a
recommendation
they're often developed in-house by
necessity because there is no CE ivd
test available for what they need
and these ihds must be clinically
verified
by running them on non-patient diagnoses
and can be implemented quickly for
emergency use
the molecular tests
can include a wide variety of assays for
different applications and those of you
who have developed ivds probably have
gone into most of these markets I think
oncology is a major one of course
pathogens genes and rare disease
proteins
pharmacogenomic markers are becoming
very very hot but and then you also have
the respiratory pathogens like like
covid for example various genetic
variate variants and metabolites as well
but those are just examples
reasons a laboratory might choose to
purchase an ivd test is essentially if
it does what you need it to do for your
patient population
uh it has all of the manufacturing done
the controls are in place there's a
broader distribution you it's easier to
establish as a gold standard because you
can compare to other labs using the same
product
design controls
importantly it has notified body
guidance and Regulatory expertise so
it's set up to meet the standards of
your environment
it has adverse event reporting as a
requirement and a complete clinical
validation prior to marketing
the reasons a laboratory would choose to
develop an IHC ihd I'm sorry is that the
ihd is unique and it there's no CE ivd
assay available for sale for the same
clinical need and it might be a clinical
need in a different range of detection
for example that that's one reason that
you might modify an ivd and uh and
create your own ihd
you can't scale up an ivd for a desired
throughput and so you need to modify
it's a ihd would be an improvement over
an existing assay
it doesn't align with a desired
procedure or utility that your
clinicians require
it can be developed much more rapidly
than an IV test ivd test and sometimes
this because of pandemics for example
and the need to create assays more
quickly and ihd is the Preferred Choice
it can also help a laboratory remain
competitive
now advantages of ivds again are that
quality system is in place and so you
don't have to essentially set your own
parameters
the um
oh whoops
I don't know why you can't see me I'm
sorry but I can't control that
uh let me talk again about advantages of
ivds the inventory control is simple
because you order a kit everything you
need comes and uh you can maintain your
own inventory
the technical support is available so
the supplier can troubleshoot and
replace any sort of faulty product
the clinical validity of the test has
been proven and therefore it can ensure
that it detects or measures the analyte
that you're reporting and that is being
used for your patient care
there's a broad distribution of ivds
because of the marketing and supply
chain of the vendors so many
Laboratories utilizing the test can
compare their data and can increase or
potentially reduce confidence in it so
it's it's kind of like having your own
uh support group
advantages of ihds
are that you do have control over the
content because you've designed it for
your application and health institutions
can select specific and relevant targets
and applications for their patient
population
you can adapt you can adapt it or you
can implement it rapidly
modified relatively quickly to respond
to Market needs now remember any
modification you still have to document
and prove but you don't have to go
through as much detail as an ivd did
you can consolidate ihds into one test
testing for multiple analytes with
multiplexing makes it a much faster
diagnosis and uh it can be very helpful
for syndrome itals
the laboratory quality qualification is
that your Health institution first of
all has to comply with the general
safety and performance requirements
including ihds but with ivds the quality
management system requirements are not
mandatory until 2024.
however ISO 15189 is recommended
now in kind of a broad view
this is the typical ihd process from
planning to Launch
and you you start with setting up your
lab and accrediting it and this would be
whatever your National or institutional
requirements are it can be different in
different facilities because of
corporate management rules and Quality
Systems it can be different in different
countries but in general you have to
follow the ivdr annex one
well I run an ihd well if you go through
the planning process you say what do I
need is it available
and can I make it
what is the test or panel you would
configure that test depending on what
test menu you're trying to complement or
put together you would select the
targets that are clinically useful for
your patients
you can customize it depending on what
sort of equipment you have you would
interpret the results in the manner that
and report them in the manner that is
most helpful to your clinicians
and benefit obviously patient care
for the analytical validation you will
do a classic
validation following probably the clsi
guidelines which would cover how you
would determine an adequate sensitivity
specificity
reproducibility accuracy and also prove
that you don't have interference from
known components that might be in the
same patient sample
and you would split samples for clinical
verification
the if the tests are clinically accurate
you've verified it clinically with
samples from patients with known
diagnoses or samples that have been
previously characterized blindly by
another laboratory running a validated
test
results would be compared to check the
concordance this is also one of the
reason running proficiency tests with
exchanges between Laboratories
best practices for ihd introduction for
a test launch well you you need to let
people know that you're working on it so
you have prepared your Market
you can announce the test when it's
ready
describe the utility in educational
content forums Publications
and in this
in this reviewed publication if that's
consistent with your IP strategy which
Michael's going to talk about next I
think that
laying the groundwork for the test
launch actually is ongoing throughout
the entire analytical and clinical
validation process
Michael
all right
thank you Marilyn all right
good afternoon good morning everyone uh
as Maryland mentioned I am Michael
Donovan uh I am going to
there we go uh I am going to talk about
two different uh sets of League
leaves that are very important for
Diagnostics regular and intellectual
property first we're going to talk about
regulation going to continue an economy
that that Maryland with Democrats
between ivds and ihds
um and again remember ivds are more
product driven
um and they're about regulating a thing
in this case a diagnostic whereas ihds
are more about the process in terms of
what is going on in a Clinical
Laboratory
um now all of you probably recognize
that as of May 26 this year ivdr went
live and devices or in vitro Diagnostics
in our case that are marketed to third
parties are now subject to a whole slew
of new
um regulatory hurdles
um some of the biggest some of the the
the new regulatory architecture to which
um idds are subjected to our harmonized
standards from standard setting
organizations including
um ISO one three four eight five which
is a quality management system that is
in place for medical device faxers
um there is also
um depending on the the specification of
a given ivd there's significant
nice with Conformity elements as well as
appropriate regulatory approve uh
approval
now significantly one of the big shifts
from the ivdd which is kind of the the
precursor regulatory system to the ibdr
is the implementation of a risk-based
classification
previously there were simple categories
um and if your ivd did not fit into one
you were basically left to self-regulate
now with these risk-based classification
systems which I'm going to talk about
next
um you have a whole new uh set of
regulatory obligations that are
associated with this process and then
one last thing just to mention on IV
thesis is um some of the post-marketing
surveillance and controls Adverse Events
uh adverse event reporting as Marilyn
mentioned now in contrast to that
um ihds on the other hand are not
explicitly defined under ivbr but on the
uh but they are also not excluded rather
they are regulated by implication under
Article Five Five of of the ibdr
um those of you who do loved ihds are
regulated uh by a competent Authority in
your particular jurisdiction now one
thing to keep in mind is ihds under the
ivdr are only permissible to be
developed and and
um commercialized by Health institutions
and that is a a term specifically
defined in ibdr as an organization whose
primary purpose is the carer treatment
or the protection of Public Health so
these are things like hospitals clinical
Labs Public Health Laboratories
um these are our organizations that that
are there to um uh to to protect the
public health so those are the only
organizations that can actually roll out
a nihd ibdr additionally and in 2028 so
this is forward looking at this point
will eventually require justification
for the use of an ihd but and I'll talk
a little bit more about that in a bit
but in terms of the the process that is
regulated again there's there's
performance uh documentation that's
required there's the same ISO standard
that Maryland mentioned 15189 which is
quality management for clinical
laboratories as well as that particular
laboratory's institutional Regional and
National requirements
now as I mentioned
um one of the big changes is the
implementation of risk-based
classification uh present in ivdr I'm
not going to go into too much detail
here
um but this this risk-based
classification is based on a combination
of risk factors tied to both public
health risk as well as personal risk uh
and that risk is is closely tied in with
what a uh an incorrect uh or an
erroneous result might give rise to so
class D
um is actually the highest risk category
uh and class D covers um certain things
uh that like um re-test for
transmissible agents in the blood supply
as well as biological materials that
might be transplanted or readministered
um also blood grouping and tissue typing
such as [ __ ] systems rhesus systems Cal
kid and Duffy testing
um so that is those are the highest risk
and then you slowly move down uh in
terms of lower risk uh Technologies such
as those that have high personal risk so
again this might be something where you
have
um you're looking at infectious disease
Diagnostics or cancer Diagnostics or
cancer screening as well as some
e which is a little bit again less risk
um where you're looking at at things
like cholesterol testing urinalysis as
well as certain exempt self-tests like
uh pregnancy and fertility tests uh one
important aspect to know in terms of
Class B is that that is the default
category uh if for some reason your test
doesn't really qualify under any other
category
uh and then finally we've got class a uh
which is basically broadly speaking
laboratory devices
um for example PCR machines would be
considered non-sterile Class A also
things like wash buffers other
instruments and specimen receptacles so
again
um the really important take-home Point
here is to is that you have these
different risk um classifications but go
along with that you also have different
levels of regulatory scrutiny that are
placed by notified bodies so the
regulatory scrutiny for a Class D device
is going to be much more significant
than for a class a device and in fact
some of those Class A non-sterile uh
devices are are actually default to um
uh self-certification kind of the the
old way of certifying under ivdd
now just briefly
um let's see here while this pulls out
so the class selection process how do we
figure out
um into which class uh an IBD might be
classified is actually initially uh the
burden is initially on the um the
manufacturer so it is up to the
manufacturer to file a predetermined set
of rules in order to figure out uh which
class they fall in their device falls
into and these rules basically ask
certain questions about
um the the what the device is intended
to actually test for so right here in
rule one as I mentioned some of the
highest risk associated devices are
going to be things like blood screening
in particular for infectious diseases
that that could be easily transmissible
through their blood supply so those are
very high risk that is going to be a
Class D and again you're going to have
the highest level of regulatory scrutiny
in terms of um uh what those notified
bodies are actually going to do and then
you proceed down from basically left to
right
um in terms of asking these questions
and delivering various answers until you
get down to rule six where basically you
have
um a kind of none of the above type of
answer in which case you default uh to
class B so again
um there are there's some great
information out there in terms of these
specific questions that have to be asked
if you
um
uh you did need to um
you do need to to ask these questions in
order to figure that out and then once
you make that determination and submit
an application uh to a notified body
they will verify your analysis as a
manufacturer
so one last note on ihds uh in article
5.5 as there are specific there are
actually five specific requirements that
fall under article 5.5 the first one
um uh America touched on which is you're
required to comply with Annex one
um which is the general safety and
performance requirements our gspr
um there's that action new stuff I think
there's 23 or 24 gstrs
um and within those there's actually
subsets so there are lots of
requirements to keep in mind there
um uh in addition and Maryland also
touched on this devices cannot be
transferred to another entity
um so basically a Health institution can
develop and roll out an ihd but on the
other hand it has to stay within that
Health institution
um and to to kind of tail with that
um you have this these these ihds again
are processes and they can and not be
scaled up to a large industrial scale
they have to remain on that that local
level again though iddr is is new and
it'll be interesting to see how
industrial scale ends up being defined
um from a regulatory process
um
and then in addition to that you have
quality management uh systems
requirements ISO 15189 which as Marilyn
mentioned it's not quite required yet it
will be in a couple years but it is
something that is highly advisable to
follow so that um you have uh you have
good compliance procedures in place and
then finally
um justification is going to be required
this is not the case yet uh it kicks in
and I believe 2028 but for for health
institutions that want to roll out an
ihd as of 2028 if there is a CE ivd
already on the market
um they that Health institution is going
to have to put forth a justification for
the development and commercialization of
that ihd so it is something to keep in
mind as of right now that's not
necessary but it will be down the road
so next I'm just going to touch very
briefly on some intellectual property
issues
um there are basically two sides to IP
as far as from a simplistic standpoint
there's obtaining coverage on one hand
and then there's going to be uh strategy
and potentially avoiding other people's
patents on the other hand uh with
respect to obtaining IP protection
um the European patent office is kind of
what I'm going to focus on in terms of
their rules and regulations
um it can be quite challenging depending
on what your assay is and what platform
you're using for your assay if you're
using conventional Technologies and
you're using conventional or previously
known biomarkers so for example if
you're going to develop a a qpcr a new
qpcr assay for uh bracha 1 bracket two
um it's going to be a challenge to
obtain patent coverage for that because
those are obviously qpcr is well known
as are those two markers
respect or an inventive step tied in
there but at the same time you um you
need to be able to demonstrate that to
the PTO or sorry to the EPO
um you can be able you may be able to
obtain protection for novel platforms so
for example uh if you are able to come
up with some type of new way of
Performing these Diagnostics that could
be protectable and or improvements to
Conventional platforms those things can
be protected
um but that kind of the the big issue in
the European Union is the statutory
prohibition on protecting diagnostic
methods
um there were actually uh it is one of
the the
um uh it is explicitly recited in
European pan office regulations that you
cannot protect a diagnostic method that
is performed on a human or animal body
and there are a couple of key decisions
coming out of the epos
um uh Board of patent appeals that
actually set forth in terms of figuring
out what those uh what is a diagnostic
method and it might sound um common
sense at this point but as of 2005 it
was not necessarily so
um in 2005 it was set forth that
basically a diagnostic method is a
collection of data it's comparison of
data it's an analysis of the data and
then it is a diagnosis based on that
data so those are the key steps that
have to be present for that that that
preclusion to actually apply and then in
2008 there was actually a bit of a
reprieve in particular for the in vitro
Diagnostics uh industry where where you
have again the same uh the same Judicial
Court setting forth what does perform
done mean from a human or animal body
perspective and this gets back to
actually Maryland's first slide which
was something that is performed in the
laboratory so if as long as the
diagnostic methodology is performed on a
specimen from a human or an animal body
as opposed to actually being performed
on a human or animal
um it is something that that doesn't
trigger that prohibition so putting
someone into an MRI tube that's going to
be something that will trigger the
prohibition
um taking a specimen like a biopsy and
running maybe some genetic screening for
melanoma that's something that that will
not be prohibited so long as you don't
explicitly recite requirements
um for uh actually contacting that that
human or animal body
now on the flip side
we have pre-commercialization concerns
in terms of freedom to operate this
boils down to avoiding patent
infringement which can be quite
expensive for your organization
um as such as early as the possible in
the development process it is always a
good idea to engage counsel either
internal counsel or an external counsel
to conduct basically a patent search to
figure out what patents are out there in
the particular technological space that
you are looking to to exploit the
results of that search may result in the
results of that search may lead to
either the preparation of certain legal
opinions such as invalidity or
non-infringement opinions uh or it may
even end up requiring your organization
to in-license patents if those um if
those uh the the owners of those pets
are willing to to make it feel uh to
help you avoid
um infringement concerns in the future
and one final note is this fto process
can actually provide some good guidance
in terms of obtaining patents you might
be able to find something out there
there that may not pose an infringement
concern but could still inform us to in
terms of what protection you can and
cannot get
um now with that I will turn it back
over to Mara as she is uh going to touch
thank you Michael and thank you Marilyn
for a fantastic overview of the key
issues around the lab I'm going to end
um our presentation piece leave time for
questions to talk about a topic that
maybe you've had enough of but we I'm
going to give a very brief overview of
covid-19 Diagnostics and how
um that is interacting with our world
um as we look at covid-19 Diagnostics
I'm going to show what has changed over
time it started that the diagnostic was
a very invasive one a bronchial lavage
we moved to PCR and viral antigen tests
for active disease diagnosis we then
move to screening and I believe in the
future it will all be about surveillance
testing as the active stage of the
pandemic
moves forward and what I mean by that
are air quality monitoring breath tests
covet sniffing dogs scratch and sniff
tests and waste water most importantly
here waste water
and what's been important about those is
that they moved from as I mentioned very
invasive tests in the lungs to the back
of the nose to the front of the nose and
ultimately most of these screenings will
be passive and non-invasive with saliva
or even breath
where are these tests happening from the
hospital to the central lab to the point
of care to home but I want to emphasize
here because all of you most of you are
in Central Labs well I believe that most
of the testing will go home in terms of
volume there will always be an important
place in the central lab for PCR and
other molecular tasks for covid and
other infectious diseases but for covet
in particular as it moves to the lab out
of the lab for the majority of the tasks
not the most aggressive ones we'll see
the price go down
so how many tests are out there if you
look at this and this is from
testing.com which is maintained by
Arizona State University in the U.S and
I've worked on this you can get a sense
of the number of tests just over 450 in
the U.S with euas but the CE European
self-certification that you're all
familiar with has approved the most
number of euas or authorize those
a comment here that there are a number
of those that are antibody tests which
is the vast majority in the U.S while we
authorized a lot of antibody tests many
of them were then pulled back from
authorization so to give you a sense
here is the vast majority of our tests
are indeed molecular from Labs like
yours covet test but we see that 88 or
PCR
then isothermal we have two percent
sequencing and one percent crispr I
believe that PCR will continue to
dominate that field but we'll have a
small number of tests in the lab that
are full sequencing based or crispr base
how does covet compare and well this
isn't about Diagnostics I felt that this
was a very interesting perspective to
look at how covet has changed over time
this is a look of the worst and most
challenging epidemic threats that our
world has seen going back several
hundred years and looking at case
fatality rate and infectiousness or
transmissibility with an R naught and
you can see how we started at a higher
fatality rate
and moved to a less and less fatality
rate in the U.S and much of Europe
equivalent to the flu however Omicron is
much more contagious this is critical
obviously for society but I'm going to
say it's also critical for testing
because testing
um especially the very accurate PCR
testing is the only way to slow a surge
what we know about covid is that very
many people have covid but do not have
any symptoms but are still transmissible
and testing is the only way to find
those people
so to summarize
um and give our conclusion ihgs are a
very important instrument for Diagnostic
Innovation
um The ihd's Leverage regulations that
provide Labs the ability to quickly
adapt to changing needs and that's so
important the ihds as Maryland
emphasized function through lab
processes while ivds are licensed as
tests and Labs really need to recognize
and optimize the processes and
procedures to do this well
ihds and ivds can work together for
patient care and as we heard from
Marilyn and Michael continue those tests
to support medical research and
development and both types of tests make
personalized medicine and better care
available as a reality for patients
so with that if you have any questions
we're going to talk about them live but
I wanted to share all of our email
addresses and if you have questions to
follow up afterwards please feel free to
email us we will now go to our live q a
and see what questions please submit
your questions in the ask a question box
and with that I will give you
a moment to look at that we've had a
couple of questions
come through initially
um
Michael and Marilyn I'm having a little
bit of trouble with my system can you
um
call up the first question
sure sure
um sorry for the technical difficulties
in my presentation all
um I I did not realize that that my
video was freezing quite as much as it
was
um so but I heard you fine Michael so it
worked out that's good
um
uh the first question is Laboratories in
the European region are still allowed to
develop in-house assays under the new
ivdr can you confirm
um so I can I can answer that which is
yes they are
um the article five five of ivbr makes
clear
um that there are permissible
opportunities for health institutions
um to um uh to develop
um ihds but at the same time uh
everything you do still have to comply
uh with those um uh with those rules in
article five five and more importantly
um not everyone can develop them you
have to meet the definition of a a
Health institution
thank you for that sure
um next question that came in was about
the presentation and existing documents
to recap what we went through and any
additional details Michael I think
you've done some work on that
yes there is I mean I I can actually
refer you to the thermal Fisher team as
well
um uh because we have our group put
together
um some good present our good
Publications some white papers on um uh
uh on these various topics that that
we've put forward
super the next question Marilyn goes to
you do I need to justify the development
of an ihd now or it is under the new
ivdr if there already is a ceivd assay
with identical specifications on the
market
uh I would say no uh just based on the
the definition of uh an ihd uh Michael
what what do you think uh if you there's
some modification perhaps but if it's
exactly the same uh I don't think you
can develop an ihd
you uh so for the the for the short time
uh I think it's until 2028 you're
allowed to and then 2028 is kind of
where the the
um ivd ivdr comes down on on ihds
um that's where where you really kind of
see the the limitation there where you
need that justification
um before you start developing um
because it is I I think that there is um
just from my personal perspective I
think there is this bias against against
ihds in the ivdr it's a lot of a lot of
letters
um that uh that they there there is uh
more and more uh roadblocks being put in
the way for for ihd rollout
and I think a lot of those roadblocks
actually came from large medical
institutions which didn't want to take
on any legal questions so that was the
basis of my answer
sure no absolutely
super so let me ask a a question here
um on the difference for labs who work
in the U.S and in Europe
how do they manage that are there any
differences in terms of probably to you
Marilyn in terms of set up for labs that
they're based in Europe but they'd also
like to have their tests available for a
U.S audience
uh yes that that's generally a corporate
decision and it has to do with the
quality system that the company is using
but in general uh large organizations
standardize and would like to do the
same in all of their facilities to
provide the same patient care
if it's a a question of a one-off uh I I
think you could do different methods but
it sure wouldn't be as easy to control
fair enough in terms of that laboratory
system putting that system into place
what are one of the what I'll call
always and Nevers if for because we know
about a fourth uh forty percent of our
audience have not developed a test in
the past is it critical to have that
laboratory system in place when you go
through the initial part of your process
and if you're upgrading your system
um what are some good watch outs that
you should think about in terms of
putting in a new system
when you say system are you talking
about Lis or workflow process yes
yes I I well I I was actually thinking
about the Lis system
okay uh well you can you can use
multiple Lis systems if you have a labs
in different locations and they are
managed by different las's and as long
as they can capture the relevant
information and you can standardize your
quality control you can standardize the
percentage of positivity you see in a
certain patient population and you can
actually compare with proficiency
testing between facilities so the Lis
really is a vehicle to document results
and patient information I don't think it
has to be standardized for a company
and how long does it typically take to
put in a new system and how much
training is required
wow that that's that is a very very
difficult question uh if you have a
small laboratory and one technology
to implement an Lis
for a single test can take you between
six months and a year
and if you have a large laboratory with
multiple Technologies and many different
tests you're looking at one to two years
got it but I'm assuming that most of the
larger Laboratories
um probably have some sort of Lis system
in place so it's probably more about
training new employees and upgrades
it's training users
that has to go along with that to
document that the workflow is capturing
all of the right data and that the
results that go through various
platforms of testing come out at the end
with a quality controlled result going
to the clinician and or the patient
super
so I'm going to switch a little bit
Michael a question to you about legal
status you've talked about the
intellectual property I often get
questions about trademarks and
trademarking test names for many labs
they really want to establish that their
lab is doing something unique or putting
together a unique process with service
to the customers how does the trademark
system work in terms of creating a
unique name for your product
I mean the the trademark system is is
um it's it's much more forgiving than is
the patent system from uh from uh
inventive step novelty perspective I
mean you a trademark is uh in general
viewed as kind of consumer protection uh
uh a consumer protection based policy so
that you have a a Mark um it could be a
trademark which is generally associated
with Goods or a service Mark which might
be associated with some of those ihds
like we talked about
um but basically as long as you are the
one
um who is the first to use that Mark or
the I guess the uh someone else may have
ceased using that Mark and you have kind
of picked up the torch if you will
um that is a it is a good way to try to
establish a
um a brand especially in those
situations where you might not be able
to get patent coverage
so if you've got a great brand
um obviously still complying with all
the the regulatory aspects that I talked
about but you're you launch a test even
though there might not be patent
protection available for it trademark
protection is still something that that
is um that can set you apart uh from
competitors
super thank you and now we'll go back to
the regulation we have a question from
Italy for those products that will not
be quote certified ivdr but were but it
was a ceivd for instance some probes for
fish analysis how will the lab have to
manage that situation again not be
certified ivd or IV ivdr but was ceivd
so depending on the class that they fall
into
um so something like that I I would
think it would be Class B
um there are there will have to be
um uh basically re-certifications under
ivdr so things that are already on the
market
um that were that had previously been
um regulated under ivdd
um or I guess kind of not regulated
under IBD kind of fell through the the
self-regulation loophole
um that was present there
um there will be there's a a
um and it's tied into the risk
categories
um there there is a gradual phasing in
of those having to go through that
regulatory process so Class B I think
doesn't have to be phased in until
I think it's 2026 or 2027.
um So eventually those will have to be
um to comply with ivdr just not quite
yet
super Marilyn anything to add there
no uh I have to say that
for fish analysis
pretty straightforward uh reagents and
so I think what the laboratory can do to
protect itself is to uh to do extensive
uh analytical validations on those
probes to be sure that the sensitivity
and specificity is correct and then
Michael I think it's it's just a few
little steps to to go further
yeah no I mean the regulatory burden for
I think like I said I think this would
be a Class B for the probes themselves
um I don't think the regulatory burden
is is is all that much I mean especially
if they've been in use and you've got
plenty of data already
um uh on on the use of those those
probes I don't think it would be that
much of a of a hurdle I think that
there's going to be just more quality
management as well as potentially uh
post-marketing surveillance
um that you're gonna have to to comply
with
super so with that I'm just gonna put
back up the screen with
um email addresses if you have any
questions please be in touch and Elena
over to you to conclude but thank you
everybody for being with us today
thank you Mara Marley and Michael for
your time today and you're really
informative presentation we'd also like
to thank labroots for hosting today's
webinar in their platform and of course
thank you thank you all for joining us
today please don't forget this webinar
can be viewed on demand lab root will
alert you via email when it's available
for a play we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who
might have missed today's live webinar
thank you and goodbye